There was a lot of concern earlier this morning...
...because this frightening standoff actually played out on live TV.
Using LoJack, authorities manage to track the car to San Diego County.
They chased it down, stopping at the ramp from Route 52 to Route 67.
Just before 9 AM, two of the young boys got out of the Toyota Camry.
One boy was first, got out, shut the door, and walked to the waiting officers.
Shortly after, the second boy gets out quickly and runs.
About an hour went by with no action...
...but authorities say they were on the phone with Daniel Perez.
And officers put themselves in strategic position with rifles at the ready.
Finally, officers made their move.
An armored vehicle pulls right up to the front of the car...
...and then one pins it in from the back.
Perez decided to make his own move.
He got out of his car, on the phone, appearing to drag one of his sons with him.
The other one followed.
Quickly, the officers moved in.
Perez even looks like he's trying to jump to his death.
He's dragged down and put in handcuffs...
...while more officers grabbed the boys and walked them to safety.
So again, all of those boys, all four boys appeared to be physically okay.
They're in protective custody right now.
Perez, their father, was taken to the CHP office in El Cajon.